Looking for a thrilling movie night, but stuck
on what to watch?
Don't worry, Netflix is jam-packed with great
thrillers that'll send a chill up your spine.
From criminally overlooked heist flicks to
gritty, hard-boiled revenge tales, here are
all the best thrillers on Netflix that nobody
seems to be talking about.
Small Crimes
Directed by Evan Katz, 2017's Small Crimes
takes Jaime Lannister out of Westeros and
sticks him in the middle of small town America.
Played by Nikolaj Coster-Waldau, Joe Denton
is a corrupt cop recently released from prison
after carving up the local DA.
Now that he's a free man, this alcoholic narcissist
is trapped in limbo, with everyone giving
him the evil eye.
His mom is pressuring him to clean up his
life, his wife and kids won't talk to him,
and random strangers are trying to bash his
head in.
E across
Worse still, a sleazy police lieutenant wants
Joe to take out a dying gangster to make sure
the mobster doesn't squeal on all the dirty
cops in town.
But really, this is a movie that defies plot
description, as Small Crimes delves into some
twisty plotlines involving prostitution, drunken
soldiers, and a deranged gangster with his
own personal torture dungeon.
Coster-Waldau is at his best here, and this
complicated plot unfolds with a gut-punch
of a final showdown, one that will leave you
looking at the deadbeat protagonist in a completely
different light.
Despite all the twists and turns, Small Crimes
is ultimately a movie about forgiveness and
whether or not we deserve it.
The Crying Game
Directed by Neil Jordan, The Crying Game was
hailed as one of the best films of 1992, but
in subsequent years, it's been overshadowed
by some of its cinematic cousins.
That's a shame, because this moody thriller
has it all, from heart-wrenching romance to
hair-pulling tension.
The film follows an IRA terrorist named Fergus
who befriends a British soldier, played by
Forest Whitaker.
Unfortunately for their friendship, Fergus
is supposed to shoot the poor trooper.
Whitaker's character asks Fergus to check
on his girlfriend after he's gone.
Eventually Fergus leaves the IRA, travels
to London, and meets Dil, the soldier's girlfriend.
He quickly falls for her, but that whole "I
shot your boyfriend" secret is always looming
in the background.
It doesn't help matters that the IRA is busy
looking for Fergus, wanting to bring him back
to the fold.
Honestly, there's a lot more going on in this
film than we can possibly say.
So if you want to experience the entire emotional
experience then you'll definitely want to
visit Netflix and try playing The Crying Game.
Cartel Land
Produced by Kathryn Bigelow and directed by
Matthew Heineman, Cartel Land is a visceral
thriller that feels a lot like The Hurt Locker
or Zero Dark Thirty.
The only difference is that Cartel Land is
a documentary.
There are no actors, no script, just real-life
people armed to the teeth.
This white-knuckle 2015 thriller follows two
vigilante groups on opposite sides of the
border as they battle incredibly violent Mexican
cartels.
We witness actual gunfights, real-life torture,
and one of the most harrowing car rides in
cinematic history.
The movie also takes a nuanced look at the
issue, showing how vigilantes are fighting
for their lives against gangs.
On the other hand, these vigilante groups
have a tendency to go overboard, and over
on the American side, there's some horrible
racism fueling their efforts to hunt down
people who come across the border.
"Why would you put two races in the same nation
and expect them to get along."
Cartel Land plunges viewers right into the
blood-and-guts-reality of the drug war, and
even though it's a documentary, it's as thrilling
as any fictional film you'll ever see.
The Gift
Written and directed by Joel Edgerton, The
Gift is a creepy little suspense flick from
2015 that will make you think twice when an
old friend calls and wants to catch up.
The plot follows Simon and Robyn Callem, a
seemingly happy couple played by Jason Bateman
and Rebecca Hall.
They've gone through some trauma, but now
they're looking to start over in a new city,
in a new house, and with new lives.
Unfortunately for the couple, Simon runs into
an old friend from school, a man named Gordo.
"Gordo the weirdo."
"That's not very nice."
"Everybody had a name."
At first, Gordo just seems a little too eager
to please, but as strange gifts show up on
the Callems' porch and tensions escalate,
it looks like Gordo might have more on his
mind than reminiscing about the good old days.
That's just scratching the surface of the
story, and without saying much more about
the plot, The Gift is a tense and nasty little
movie with unsettling performances from its
three brilliant leads, not to mention an ending
that will likely leave you genuinely upset.
A Patch of Fog
If you've seen Boardwalk Empire, then you
know Stephen Graham can be one intimidating
dude, and he brings that same manic energy
to A Patch of Fog.
In this atmospheric 2015 film, Game of Thrones'
Conleth Hill plays a famous author named Sandy
Duff who's living off the proceeds of a 20-year-old
book.
When he's not giving lectures or appearing
on TV, he spends his spare time shoplifting,
which majorly backfires when he's caught by
a psycho security guard named Robert, played
by Graham.
However, Robert doesn't want to turn Sandy
over to the police.
Robert just wants to be friends.
Obviously, when a super stalker wants to be
your buddy, that's never a good sign, and
their freaky friendship soon escalates to
a game of cat-and-mouse with some very serious
stakes.
"You make it sound like I wanna stick pins
in ya."
"I just wanna be your friend."
While we've seen similar stories before, the
highlight here is the tension between Graham
and Hill, both playing characters we empathize
with, even though we wouldn't necessarily
want to hang out with either one of them.
Buster's Mal Heart
Thrillers don't come much stranger than 2016's
Buster's Mal Heart.
Written and directed by Sarah Smith, the movie
finds Rami Malek playing a bearded mountain
man on the run from the cops.
This outlaw hobo is named Buster, and when
he's not breaking into cabins, he's ranting
about an upcoming apocalypse he calls "The
Inversion."
But how did Buster get to this place, with
gun-wielding cops on his trail?
Well, you'll start to find out as the film
jumps back to when Buster was a family man
named Jonah.
Clean-shaven and suffocating, Jonah is a hotel
concierge who feels trapped by the system…until
a conspiracy theorist shows up with wild ideas
about Y2K and robbing banks.
Making all this even stranger, we occasionally
get glimpses of a third version of Malek,
lost at sea, adding to the uneasy dream vibe
of the whole film.
Buster's Mal Heart has some twists that will
keep you guessing, but ultimately, it's a
mind-bending movie that will cause you to
praise Rami Malek's acting abilities while
questioning the nature of reality itself.
The Fury of a Patient Man
Set in Madrid, The Fury of a Patient Man follows
a seemingly gentle man named Jose who falls
in love with a lonely woman named Ana.
Her husband, Luis, has been behind bars for
his part in a jewel heist, and of course,
we all know things are going to get messy
when he's finally released.
But just when you think you know where it's
going, the movie sets off in an entirely different
direction.
This brutal 2016 Spanish-language film features
some brilliantly suspenseful scenes, like
a tense moment in a boxing gym and a one-shot
car chase that ends in a terrific wreck.
Bad Day for the Cut
Set in Northern Ireland, 2017's Bad Day for
the Cut is gory proof that you don't mess
with farmers, and you especially don't mess
with farmers' moms.
This film focuses on a middle-aged man named
Donal, a farmer who's spent most of his life
taking care of his elderly mother.
But his quiet existence is turned upside down
when she's killed after what seems to be a
home invasion gone wrong.
After joining forces with another victim,
Donal sets out to collect an eye for an eye,
but he quickly realizes there are quite a
few secrets in his family tree.
Still, that doesn't stop him from taking on
an army of bad guys to take revenge against
the crime lord responsible for taking out
his mom.
If you're a fan of crime flicks from the UK,
Bad Day for the Cut will definitely be a good
time on Netflix.
Icarus
Directed by Bryan Fogel, 2017's Icarus picked
up the Oscar for Best Documentary at the 90th
Academy Awards.
The film opens with Fogel wanting to explore
the world of performance enhancing drugs by
injecting himself with all kinds of chemicals
before competing in a bike race.
His little stunt soon leads him to Dr. Grigory
Rodchenkov, a colorful character and the man
in charge of Russia's anti-doping program.
Soon, Rodchenkov is fearing for his life,
and we watch as he maneuvers around KGB agents,
escapes the country, and faces the possibility
of assassination.
A documentary that will have you on the edge
of your seat, Icarus is the perfect mix of
informative storytelling and real-life thrills.
Shimmer Lake
Sort of like Fargo crossed with Memento, Shimmer
Lake is a backwards story of bumbling criminals
who can't stop screwing up.
Taking a page from the Christopher Nolan playbook,
this 2017 Netflix Original starts at the end
and works its way toward the beginning, as
a group of small-town crooks plan and carry
out a robbery.
"Yeah Chris, it's going real good. Super good!"
Without a doubt, the highlight of the film
is Benjamin Walker as Zeke Sikes, a local
sheriff who walks softly, carries a big stick,
and is forced to deal with everything from
idiot FBI agents to a devious femme fatale.
Rainn Wilson is also great as Zeke's brother
Andy, a disgraced attorney who plays a key
role in the twisty plot.
If you've seen James Gunn's Super, then you
know Wilson has impressive dramatic chops,
and he's pretty great here as a despicable,
desperate loser.
"Where have I been?"
"Where have I been?
In a car, forever.
A corn field.
I spent the night in a junkyard."
And if the backwards timeline sounds a bit
gimmicky, don't worry.
It pays off beautifully, making Shimmer Lake
a dark tale that's totally worth unraveling.